okay guys we are back in the last
episode we went through a crazy
conundrum [ __ ] and it looks like we woke
up from the delusional state and we're
just gonna say what's going on well sir
I think I woke up like over here yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
so woke up like right here because you
guys forgot basically they supposedly an
FBI agent on the other side so we gonna
unlock the door
something dark my flashlight no I guess
was it dreams I don't really have one
doors lock doors oh it could be anything
let's see what this has see ya and then
renovation work and humane [ __ ] I was
just fired and what just [ __ ] fired
I guess doesn't happen in the corporate
world you know you don't do good the
company doesn't do holy [ __ ] this
thing's going on forever hey bat bang
what is that
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] scary you know
what that's gonna be about holy [ __ ]
anything in here anything well other
this room is very you can get in we
can't do [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm over the
drinks okay this is locked the - I think
that's [ __ ] blocked let's say let's say
that's locked if I remember again here
we go
it's a way that the light stays like in
the air that's cooled up no no I like it
that's snake massive TV the [ __ ] can't
you [ __ ] here is an endless loop yeah
it's a loop
I know if not yeah alright alright no
facility idiot turned for cellphones
make sure nobody's following winters
facility is closed five years ago nobody
comes anymore um well the drugs came
from range
okay [ __ ] I'm gonna write this down oh
my god
did
okay okay hey I got it
four seven eight
four seven eight - okay jzuk fucking's
[ __ ] scary
okay well we got the code
it is like a loop or something I can't
quite tell what the loop is what the
[ __ ] oh wait now I got to go back to the
original [ __ ] [ __ ] how do I get back he
was over here
and away go that's why I was like where
the hell we put in the code I forgot
that word this is what we're gonna hear
for I think it's four seven eight to the
[ __ ] somewhere oh [ __ ] I never go be
here yes
maybe this is like locked oh [ __ ]
this is dirty [ __ ] scary
[ __ ]
[ __ ] hammer go block whoa okay we got
something different here man this guy's
still tripping acid or something oh [ __ ]
I'm locked in the John again I hear
something
great
[ __ ] Eagles someone's [ __ ] cooking
like a dick here Certificate of Good
Conduct range a lot of money holy [ __ ]
well that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] go straight there now [ __ ] it go
city
eviction notice
yeah
[ __ ] jump-scare City I can jump scare
City pretty soon I know
[ __ ] what sure was it she's going here
that was [ __ ] locked
holy [ __ ] which one was it
this one so four holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
that oh great
we're back in this [ __ ] hole again candy
I said oh now
wait go back
I mean this room again
there we go
things through might try to get into
well these the ones that are dark as
[ __ ] [ __ ]
fucking-a here we go
and bear it out
nothing dark that [ __ ] here's the horse
she [ __ ] again it's getting [ __ ] up
yep
[ __ ] scary ass [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] quiet - here we go ready
here here go here we go
they're always done
[ __ ]
I'm betting we enter it through so many
I can't I'm like lost there was a lock
or somewhere
what the [ __ ] okay maybe I can finally
go to that one all the way on this side
oh yeah that's probably what it is
[ __ ] hey [ __ ] rude
okay we're looking for another key oh
here it is
four seven eight - that's what I'm
talking about baby
whoa
okay so they [ __ ] went after how much
forget to these drawers so I should wow
what a dirty [ __ ] what what can be
useful
don't [ __ ] it are useful Oh
the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is that
trying to wrap my head around I need a
cake not kale desk somewhere
oh right there okay okay
I should like this one I think I like
this one
anything in there there's a jump-scare
yeah we're still over - from one of
these bad boys
no [ __ ] a3 b1 d4 c5 g3
and looking for anything that's useful
because he said that could be useful
this one
[ __ ] checkmark
okay so I know it's when it is that at
least I think it's this one
[ __ ] tired well anyway this is how we
they always play it you know you finally
get a hand up and you're like yes I
solved it and there's gonna be some
[ __ ] jump-scare
no sorry I'm taking a picture of this
bad boy
get in the [ __ ] out of here okay
now look at Journal now hung up the
South okay here we go
a 3 B 1 D 4 C 5 B 3 ok so the first one
is a 3 y b1 a d45 C 5
bb3
is tea I don't know what the [ __ ] that
is
it smells y85 bTW a 3 B 1 D 4 C 5 and B
3 okay it's just like this garbage thing
yeah what's this oh my god yeah there we
go
holy [ __ ] what do you want from me he
holds us thinks so weird what the [ __ ]
second jump-scare now what
holy [ __ ] that was the end scary
holy [ __ ] wow that was a really well
done game really good I don't know it
was really polished I would say a couple
small things like every time we open a
door makes the same exact creak noise
like a gate I mean but other than that
everything was well done but that's the
level design was really good the jump
scares were actually very unique
everything I thought would happen it's
kind of turn on tight a little bit I
thought there'd be more flash jump
scares there wasn't and as unless you
jump here's the middle just like walking
and there was good in and it wasn't too
cheap either because it was about like a
gluten mine so very good I think even
the plot was interesting and I really
liked that they took some stuff from PT
but they didn't do too much of it they
did it like once maybe it's just
thinking homage version my dad um don't
know very good I liked it I liked a lot
I recommend it - Lance team for enough
how much money surprise time
I think we asked them for more
[Music]